This episode of DNews is brought to you by
Squarespace.
We love the moon cause it’s close to us.
we love the… quasi-orbital satellite?
Hey guys Julia here for DNews.
Seriously the moon is awesome, it has phases
and makes the tides come and go, plus it’s
just so freaking pretty.
I wouldn’t mind another one hanging out
in the sky.
The more the merrier right?
Wait, what that’s you say?
We have another moon?
Well not so fast, we actually have a quasi-orbital
satellite called 3753 Cruithne (croo-ee-nya).
Named for the early Celtic people in the British
Isles.
It’s not technically a moon since it’s
not in orbit around Earth.
Just like us, it orbits the Sun.
It’s in orbital resonance with us, which
is when two or more bodies get stuck in a
gravitational dance with one another.
The Earth and Cruithne are at about 1 to 1
ratio, so our orbits are really similar.
At times it looks like we’re playing cat
and mouse with each other.
Except Cruithne’s path follows what’s
called a “horseshoe orbit”.
To the sun it looks like a typical elliptical
orbit, But to us on Earth, Cruithne orbit
looks kind of bean shaped.
Wondering why you haven’t seen it before?
Well… its small.
it’s only 5 kilometers wide, while the moon
is 3,476 kilometres.
plus its kind of far away, it gets closest
to earth at 30 times the distance to the moon,
which is a pretty big distance.
So Cruithne can’t be seen with the naked
eye, it takes at least a 12.5-inch telescope
to be seen.
But Cruithne isn’t the only sort of moon
we have.
A couple other planets, like Jupiter have
what are called Trojan objects, and in 2010
we found our very own.
Trojan objects are natural satellites that
share an orbit with a larger body at what
are called Lagrangian points.
These areas follow 60 degrees ahead of or
behind the bigger body, at a gravitationally
stable spot, like an island in space.
Our Trojan is named 2010 TK7 and orbits the
Sun at Earth’s L4 Lagrange point.
At 300 meters across it’s just a little
guy, although still not exactly a moon since
it doesn’t orbit around the Earth.
And then there’s 2006 RH120 - a miniature
teeny tiny moon only a few metres wide.
The Catalina Sky Survey of Arizona found it
in 2006.
It seems Earth snagged it out of solar orbit
for about 11 months and by June 2007, it was
gone.
We miss you 2006 RH120, it felt like we barely
knew you.
*sniffle*
But don’t get too sad, we have another object,
well a bit of space debris really, orbiting
us right now!
B44E is also tiny, at just a few metres across.
B44E orbits Earth about 2 to 3 times the distance
of the Moon.
It’s pretty similar to J002E3, which researchers
think might be a piece of the Apollo 12 Saturn
V rocket.
So B44E it might also be something left over
from humans going into space.
So for now second moons remain in the realm
of science fiction, but they’re still pretty
fun to think about.
We'd like to thank Squarespace for their support
of DNews.
Squarespace is the easiest way to create a
beautiful website, blog, or online store for
you and your ideas.
Squarespace features an elegant interface,
beautiful templates, and incredible 24/7 customer
support.
Try Squarespace, at Squarespace.com/dnews,
and enter offer code DNews at checkout to
get 10% off.
Squarespace.
Build it Beautiful.
Alright guys, how much would you love another
moon?
Let us know in the comments below and while
you’re at it, hit those like and subscribe
buttons and keep coming back for new DNews
every day of the week.